[Music]
man you coming at me for my music but
you listen to this old stuff almost oh
but I get a butter here with all that
pocket the truth I got a boyfriend yeah
her sake really you're gonna get her a
lot of stuff you got time my name is
star two hours daddy made me bet garden
Heights Mama and Daddy says our life is
here because our people are here we got
mr. Rufus barbecue
mr. Lewis's barbershop and daddy's store
the high school is where you go to get
jump high or pregnant we don't go there
Williamson is another world so when I'm
here I'm starvation - Oh excellent
basically Williamson star doesn't give
anyone a reason to call her ghetto and I
hate myself for doing it until the
weekend comes around I get those bugs
every time oh no no you've been ain't
gonna like ease
[Music]
out of the car you know start go back
where he told you come on I'm not
playing go back today garden Heights is
reeling after the shooting of a 17 year
old black teenager by a white police
officer we live in a complicated world
it doesn't seem that complicated to me
violence
it's the same story just a different
name
his perception changes and again he was
threatening her
it's about more than just a little it's
about black people poor people everybody
at the bottom I need to speak for him
when you ready to talk you talk don't
ever let nobody make you be quiet I mean
you start by asking
[Music]